veterans day quickly approaching  november 11th there is a woman here in  town who wants to honor the men and  women who dedicated their life to our  country don kramer's father he was a  korean war veteran he's buried at the  boulder city memorial cemetery when  kramer visited her dad's gravesite in  2019 and didn't see flags she decided to  take on the task herself  last year she placed more than a  thousand flags this year she has 5  thousand flags so far and i could come  out there on my own diamond play out  there and put three flags on my dad's  grave and call him today but i can't  walk past all those men and women who  fought for my freedom  and gave their service to our country  and and not be able to think great you  know they're being honored today  but you know what it's going to get done  it's just going to take time  well it is going to get done but she's  asking for your help you can call the  local ace hardware store in boulder city  to order the flags